so the uh first story we're gonna go to
uh we're gonna check in with our good
friends over at the babylon beach oh my
gosh and over at the babylon b every
single article okay almost all the new
ones are the image of joe biden with the
red lights and the marines behind him
yelling and we have biden abolishes
office of president and names self
supreme fuhrer
biden signs non-aggression pact with
poland but announces invasion of poland
bravo babylon be great so uh here's the
story from newsweek
joe biden compared to adolf hitler by
trump loyalists
not just trump loyalists
many people are comparing him to hitler
whether they like trump or not y'all are
just in a cult but newsweek you know
i'll give some respect to because they
have uh bhatia anger sargon who's uh
she's actually pretty good and uh tries
to keep things a bit bound so that
that's okay i'll give him that one but
take a look at this photo we got to show
this photo from the previous night we
did that watch party but this photo has
taken the internet by storm this
this is a creepy photo
everybody who is sane is questioning the
judgment of the white house team
for yeah joe rogan yeah of course joe
yeah but joe i mean joe recently said
vote republicans all the normal people
normal guys even sam harris said the
optics were bad on this one interesting
yes but sam harris and he said but
something something about my hatred of
trump
sam harris has gone insane
i i tweeted like you need an
intervention bro but we'll get into that
i want to say we'll talk about sam
harris after the trigonometry fiasco i
mean this is a prominent p but this he
is a perfect example of what's happening
now
so um if we point out here margery
taylor green look at this
she tweeted what we all saw tonight from
biden i guess when president butterbeans
is frail weak and dementia ridden the
hitler imagery was their attempt to make
him look tough while he declares war on
half of america as enemies of the state
oh or it's real
twitter blocked this video and it says
the following media includes potentially
sensitive content
i'm going to click it are you ready
click
oh
it's biden with a fake mustache and
swastikas behind them
so we had to bring in a libertarian to
ask us what's happening is is joe biden
uh declaring himself the supreme
chancellor is he asserting that for the
security and prosperity the american
republic will be reformed to the first
american empire
so i didn't think of hitler i thought of
daenerys targaryen in that in that last
i think it's the last episode where she
goes i guess she goes full nazi in that
but yeah like
um
the the imagery is super creepy and i
think that everyone should be a little
bit freaked out about it but obviously
this wasn't an accident they they didn't
like
forget to frame the shot and realize
that it was going to be this blood red
kind of imagery and so the question is
is he
desperately talking to his base because
he knows he's going to get trounced in
the midterms
and and the only thing he has left like
you know the economy sucks and people
are paying so much
for for gas and groceries and there's
there's so much collateral damage caused
by lockdowns is the only thing you have
has left is to get every single person
that's turned on by the the
authoritarian imagery to show up and
vote in the midterms
or
is
it
about
um his brain's broken is is it real like
is it real is this is it real um i think
it's real
well
they asked him today do you i think
peter ducey asked him do you
like do you really think that the trump
supporters are how did he phrase it do
you have this
a threat to or a threat do you really
think the trump supporters are a threat
he said i don't think any trump
supporters are a threat
well last night he was demented dude
come on like so i think he what he
really thinks is a threat is cultism and
he's pointing out trump's call because
he was just president but cultism is
dangerous
if he's saying i don't think any trump
supporters are a threat but he's talking
about a cult and he thinks trump
supporters are in a cult that makes no
sense it's like he's saying the
occultism of trump is dangerous but the
people themselves are not threatened no
no no i think he's walking it back
somebody tweeted they said uh the
overnights uh must have been really
really bad on this one oh for sure that
picture came out like 10 minutes after
that
i bet they were when that photo came out
let's grab that photo again when this
photo came out of biden
like geez it's crazy dude the red lights
with him going
and just one person had to be like
instead of it being blue red blue why
don't we have it be
red blue like yeah he would have been a
totally different game it would be still
weird but like this picture's never
going away i think they know it and they
know it one of the networks slowly
tweaked it and made it pink
cnn
they knew and there was blue just
outside on either side but they cropped
it someone was like this is a great idea
we're gonna write the speech and you
know what we're gonna be super patriotic
and we're going to put red right behind
him and we're going to do it at night so
it's black and red it was to scare
people it looks crazy the other part is
this whole speech he's just throwing out
buzz words i mean he says that uh
mega supporters are extremists or threat
he says that there are uh threats to
democracy he invokes charlottesville
like he is doing anything he can to be
like
supporting donald trump is supporting
the worst of the worst and i need you to
be on my side because otherwise you were
against the foundation of america this
is a crazy statement it's like classic
uh othering the other team right and
that this is this is what every
authoritarian done is has done through
history you dehumanize the opposition
so that you can do what you need to do
um i don't think it's a mistake and the
question is does he mean like i don't i
don't know what joe biden means because
he's reading a script
um i don't think he knows but his team
wrote that
with with very much a purpose of of of
minimizing the humanity of half of
america right
now that's that's what's so creepy about
it even has that line where he says like
uh not every republican is like that
it's just that their party is dominated
and it's like a
an invite to be like adam kinzinger like
you either need to align with the
democratic party even if you keep the
name republican
uh it'll throw you out yeah i was
talking to a friend about um what we
learned of our true friends when the
cult started forming and i was saying
that
you we we've known people our whole
lives
and all of a sudden these people don't
want to be friends anymore or they're
not answering texts or they're walking
away i mean larry elder told the stories
like this
and what you realize then is these
people
will say or do anything
to appear cool or to be socially
accepted but in reality they're all just
terrified and they're just saying
whoever i fear the most i will pretend
to be like
so sure enough as soon as biden loses
and he will because this stuff never
wins it never does i mean there are
periods where autocrats gain power and
then they lose power in the end it never
lasts forever
all of these people who defend this lie
for it they'll come out and be like well
i was always against it
they'll be the first and then what you
what you need to realize is
right now we're kind of lucky
in that you can see who is actually a
thinking person you can see who is
actually your real friend because you
can ask them a simple question and see
if their brain can process it so there
are a lot of people i know
that i'm like huh
i wouldn't have known that they were a
duplicitous scumbag until now so i'd
like to thank the cult for exposing all
of these people
so so fauci came out recently and said i
was always against lockdowns the biden
administration announced a couple days
ago that they were the ones that got
children back into schools
clearly the policies of this
administration and and i would i would
even broaden it the policies of
lockdowns and dehumanizing people and
telling people they can't speak telling
people they can't leave their house
telling people that they can't go to
their job and feed their families this
is all coming to to ahead
and which which goes back to my theory
that the only thing that the democrats
have
is this other rising and demonizing and
and getting every single
hardcore democrat the 34 or whatever it
is
to show up in the midterms because
midterms are low term low turnout
elections
um clearly the people that that have
been damaged are going to show up
and they're not showing up for biden
they're showing up for something else
and and that's
that's the the catastrophic future that
they're facing they knew this in 2020
and they feel the same way now biden
does not rally anyone what gets people
to vote is the hatred of donald trump so
they've been planning this for some time
we saw them propping up maga republicans
in that they were trying to get mag
republicans to win yeah because they
knew this was
this was the trajectory
now that the primaries are coming to an
end the goal demonize maga hit him all
at once
that's the plan you know one thing that
bothers me is he was saying that he
thinks that anyone that questions a free
and fair election is a danger which i
kind of like okay well how can you say
about hillary clinton i mean that's not
that's not well she did actually
question the 2016 she never stopped but
the big problem is when you have
election tallies being calculated on a
proprietary voting machine in secret
that's i would not just
default consider that free and fair
because it's in secret it's being
tallied i can't i can't see if it's free
and fair i can't see i need to see the
code did you see what carrie lake said
no so she was asked about this like
isn't donald trump you know with he's
threatening democracy or whatever and
she was like asking about elections
asking like like every democrat did
after you know the 2016 election she
said people have a right to uh to to
question the process and how is that
anti-american or a threat to this
country or whatever that's an insane
prospect
what they want to do
with the classified documents thing they
want you to think there is an authority
above the president when it comes to
classified documents they want you to
think that trump needed permission from
someone
the national archives by the way right
they they want you to think that as
commander in chief you do not have the
authority is the duly elected you know
president or whatever to do these things
and this is
every step of the way they're trying to
make you think that you actually don't
have the right to be involved in the
process when you come out and say hey
we're doing a free and fair election so
i want to see those numbers on a on a uh
you know open source machine or the
public should have access to the code
the source code we should be able to see
them tally yeah yeah of buying for the
people that's the united states they're
trying to erase all of that make you
think that there's someone else you have
to you have to bend the knee too
yeah did you know did anyone else not
know that the national archives were the
final arbiter of of what was legal for
the president to take okay
i think it's fascinating
our country's highest authority is the
acting
acting archivist of the united states
librarians everywhere are like i had no
idea this was such a path to power could
there be a worse form of hell than the
librarians taking full control seriously
well i was looking this up today because
we were kind of talking about it with
family because they were like well
my mother-in-law actually asked she was
like well what did hillary clinton do
when the fbi came for her documents and
i was like that's a great question let's
talk about that smashed their phones
with hammers bleach bleach bit the
server yep and they were all and she was
not a president yeah she didn't have the
classification authority she destroyed
cl classified is it it wasn't was it
proven that she destroyed classified
information or she just destroyed
information her staff destroyed
information was it her command
and then so she commanded her staff to
destroy information we don't know if it
was classified or not well here's how it
works
if there's uh let's let's say you know
we've got we got a truth bomb on the
table from daily wire and let's say it
was evidence or something if i came out
and said ian destroy the evidence will
you commit a crime if i said ian cleaned
the table
well i didn't do anything wrong i should
clean the table and then ian goes and
smashes the truth bomb with a hammer
nobody committed a crime
so they're like well no one really did
anything it was one guy was just
preparing a server and she was just
telling him to clean things up
yeah we get it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there